notre éditorialiste alexis poulains
ont soir alexis c'est votre sujet
préféré prolongation est celui qui vous
donne le sourire prolongation lui passe
vous êtes heureux jusqu'en 2022 les
députés en tout cas sont en débat
aujourd'hui à pas mal d'amendements on
voit c'est un texte controversé une
possibilité d'amendement après le 15
novembre et croyant encore je n'y crois
pas malheureusement et je pense que
beaucoup de français n'y croit pas on
voit bien que de toute façon la majorité
république en marche est aux ordres du
gouvernement donc si emmanuel macron
renconcé de défense sanitaire a décidé
que le pass à lithaire devait aller
jusqu'au 22 juillet au genou en juillet
2022 par la fin juillet mais le 22
juillet je sais pas pourquoi j'ai dit
loin de vieira jusqu'en juillet voire
même au-delà et c'est bien tout le
problème parce qu'il y avait une motion
de rejet on aurait pu arrêter les
discours et dire on ne perd pas de temps
à discuter d'une idée aussi stupide et
là on va avoir un débat de carton à
l'assemblée nationale avec des députés
qui vont aller dans le sens du
gouvernement pour la majorité mais même
pour certains aussi qu'ils vont se
rallier en disant il faut une précaution
et donc on va enjamber l'élection
présidentielle parce qu'il faudra avoir
recours à se passe si jamais il faut
être vigilant comme le dit gabriela
thèse si jamais une cinquième vague
pouvait arriver puis une sixième bague
qu'une septième vague enfin on voit bien
qu'il ya quelque chose de très grave
parce que finalement c'était à d'urgence
permanent 18 mois et bien il va durer
encore très longtemps si les députés
votent pour cette prolongation et c'est
une mise entre parenthèses de la
démocratie c'est inacceptable en réalité
est pourtant on vote le conseil
constitutionnel le conseil d'état valide
également et ça continue et c'est un
état de vigilance qui s'installe où
finalement on n'est plus vraiment dans
un état de liberté comme on a connu on
est en état de liberté en sursis de
manière permanente ou alors liberté
probatoire avec ce fameux parce qu'il va
falloir montrer encore les temps
malheureusement je le crains alors le
ras-le-bol des élus commencent à se
faire sentir comme en témoigne cette
tribune des mers paru aujourd'hui dans
filière au vox c'est un début de fronde
je crois que c'est un début de fronde et
puis surtout un début de réalité les
élus de terrain savent ce que ce qu'est
le pass sanitaire dans cette tribune des
mères
de sa voix il explique la journée les
enfants à l'école vont jouer au basket
dans un gymnase et le soir ces mêmes
enfants s'ils sont à l'association
sportive doivent montrer un pass
sanitaire pour jouer dans le même
gymnase donc il voit très bien que ça
n'a aucun sens comme on l'a vu quand on
a dit que le pasa litterna n'a pas lieu
d'être dans les transports en commun ni
certains rer mais par contre dans les
tgv oui comme on l'a vu sur la façon
dont il fallait le montrer d'une façon
enfin bref ce pas sanitaire n'a rien de
salutaire et les élus de terrain s'en
rendent compte et dans cette tribune ils
disent surtout que c'est un noyau de
discorde des familles sont en train de
se fâcher des gens qui jusqu'à présent
vivait ensemble sont en train de se
séparer pour rien puisque s'il passe
sanitaire fonctionner eh bien on devrait
l'arrêter le taux d'incidence est bas
dans tous les départements la
vaccination est au plus haut en europe
pour la france donc il n'y a pas de
raison de continuer ce pas sanitaire
tous les pays qui ont mis en place le
pass sanitaire l'ont arrêté dès que
l'épidémie était sous contrôle quitte à
le remettre alors on nous parle de la
lettonie on nous fait peur gabriela
talent nous parle bien sûr de cinquième
vague la réalité c'est qu'on ne doit pas
s'habituer espace sanitaire et qu'il n'a
pas à durée de manière pérenne c'est
proprement scandaleux cette société de
vigilance ne doit pas s'installer dans
nos vies et du point de vue des français
est ce que ce pass est encore acceptable
de l'ajustement du 15 novembre ou un
refus de 2,2 masse d'un système qui tend
à justement comme vous dites à devenir
pérenne je crois qu'il ya beaucoup de
français qui ont accepté l'idée du parce
qu'ils ont accepté la vaccination à deux
doses mais pour qui la troisième dose va
être un peu la dose de trop et s'ils se
passe doit rester pour les forcer à la
troisième dose alors ça risque vraiment
vraiment là de compliquer les choses
notamment chez les plus jeunes on
comprend pour les personnes à risque les
plus âgés qui ont été les premiers
vaccinés et eux donc auraient besoin à
booster mais pour ceux qui sortent de
l'été se sont fait vacciner à qui on va
demander une troisième hausse en janvier
peut-être là ça va être un peu plus
compliqué parce que pourquoi on va dire
d'ailleurs le ms n'a pas validé
forcément la troisième dose et puis la
question de la dangerosité de cette
troisième dose moderna maintenant et des
conseillers pour la troisième dose ce
n'était pas le cas il ya quelques
semaines on nous disait ya aucun danger
alesi cours isi or les pays du nord ont
émis des alertes et puis la france a
suivi avec un autorité de santé avec
quelques semaines de retard donc il ya
beaucoup de choses qu'on ne sait
toujours pas il ya beaucoup de réponses
qu'on attend et pourtant le gouvernement
veut continuer cette logique du tous
contre tous parce que divisés ça permet
de régner ça permet d'occuper le terrain
et aussi ça permet bien sûr de mettre la
présidentielle finalement sous une épée
de damoclès cdu covit celle du pass
sanitaires même si on nous garantit que
le pass and i ter ne sera jamais
utilisée pour aller voter regardez
emmanuel macron nous promettait il ya
quelques mois de cela que jamais le pass
sanitaire ne serait demandée pour les
activités du quotidien aucune confiance
dans la parole du gouvernement merci à
l'équipe hollande d'avoir été avec nous
et les mesures